we've been saying it for months the
mainstream media mob refuses to do any
vetting of joe biden now since
the end of august he has taken fewer
than half the questions that president
trump has taken from reporters
and with only 20 days until the election
the biden campaign
strategy is now clear hide keep
joe hidden from the public we the people
run out the clock
ask no tough questions tonight white
house press secretary kelly mcinerney
was locked out of a personal twitter
account after sharing that story that we
mentioned earlier about hunter biden
she wasn't alone today twitter ceo at
jack
jack dorsey is now admitting twitter's
actions
on the article were quote not great you
think jack
you're with more white house press
secretary kaley mac and any number one
how are you feeling you had your cover
diagnosis
not fun i'm sure how you feeling now
still feeling great no symptoms so i
can't complain a lot better off than a
lot of americans
were slander yeah well
well i will say you're younger and
healthier unlike me
old person i'm you know we're great at
risk which of course
nobody likes for anybody and hopefully
with the new therapeutics and vaccine on
the horizon that's all great so you got
locked out today
i really didn't understand from at jack
what he was trying to say
because if you if you share a conspiracy
you know the russia trump conspiracy
theory i don't remember people getting
locked out for those
lies that we now know they shared then
and even today still share
yeah that's exactly right it made no
sense what he said and consider this
sean
this was a news story with
emails pictures of the emails which even
the biden campaign does not dispute the
authenticity of the emails they had a
chance today they did not
uh but meanwhile your last story about
president trump in the atlantic where
you had more than 20 sources on the
record disputing
the content of the email you have the
ayatollah
between death to israel and this is
permitted on twitter
but not an email that is reported by the
way by fox news's news division
by the new york post a credible outlet
you are not
allowed to share that information and
make no mistake if they can ban the
press secretary
of the united states for president trump
they can ban
a citizen and that is pathetic that's a
great point our own adam housley on his
account has confirmed the authenticity
of
of that uh as have other media outlets
that have been
been reporting on the story i hear
there's a lot more to come
do you know what's coming
i don't um and it's not a temporary
blockage when i log on to my twitter
account it says i'm permanently banned
they essentially have me at gunpoint and
said unless you delete
a news story reported by the new york
post i cannot regain
access to my account this is censorship
it is not the american way this is not
how a
freedom-loving democracy operates and we
have told twitter accountable and
facebook too
was banning the transmission of the
story simply because ideologically
it hurts the side of the aisle that
silicon valley prefers it's sad it's
censorship
this is not america yeah well
you know it just the double standard is
very clear
when joe biden when the president in the
debate with joe biden brought up
the first lady of moscow and the three
and a half million dollar payment
we had senator ron johnson on earlier
and he confirmed
yeah that all happened just like the
russian
oligarchs the kazakh oligarchs the
russian nationals kazakh nationals
ukrainian nationals chinese nationals
and
all of these monies together i mean this
is
the biden family business while he is
vice president
imagine if the last name was trump how
do you think the mob and the media would
be acting
oh it would be all over twitter everyone
would be reporting it it'd be the top
news story it'd be the top trend on
twitter because there's
one standard for trump and another
standard uh for anything on the other
side of the
aisle but it's breathtaking that for for
years really for at least more than a
year joe biden told us
i had nothing to do with hunter's
business dealings and today we get an
email
that says hunter introduced a ukrainian
oligarch
to his father joe biden and that email
is censored
blacklisted erased from twitter and
facebook and anyone who mentions it
is banned from the public platform all
right thanks kelly we wish you continued
good health and a quick recovery as we
with
wish everybody well